you had an audition for Dreamgirls and
Fantasia Barrino who won that year she
was also up for Dreamgirls right they
were done and you probably said
psychologically oh my god she wants
they're probably gonna choose her right
that was you probably went in there
thinking I probably didn't know and feel
like at the very tail end of the
audition because it took six months to
get the role and it was 782 other people
that audition may like we searched like
the world don't you think even she had
the advantage going in on that audition
because everyone's like hey why should
we pick the seventh let's pick number
one
yeah she's got the most main question it
certainly would be a marketing yeah
thank you ever has the producers what it
was you did that got you Bill Condon
said I was the only person he felt
something from he really liked he had
you know he felt she was like he really
felt it how do you prepare for an
audition like that like what do you do
do you get the pages and you already
just go in and sing that one of those
fingers yeah well I mean again in it I
went through three different auditions
in the first audition it was the song
the song but it was only half the song
because they messed up the sheet music
and so I learned it that way right and
then I went in and I heard another lady
audition I might wait we here for the
same things she's singing the whole song
only got half of it but I want it to be
a professional you know and I didn't
want to complain or say anything so I
was like I'm gonna go in there and I'm
gonna just try to like just think it and
I blew the audition I completely messed
it up because you didn't have the right
I didn't have the right sea music and
they're not interested in your excuses
either I just wanted you think that was
curtains for you at that point um I
didn't know I know but luckily they
found out that they mixed up the sheet
music even with me ah you know messing
up they were still like no is something
new there's something they want to see
her again so when you come in again do
they have you do this song over again
they I think at that point I had I know
I had a scene and then they requested
that I sing another song that was like
in place of end
and I'm telling you but like the saying
I guess subtext right and so I did easy
to be hard I did that song which is like
from here and they like got it that
interesting that they that you did that
so that they told you to do that song or
you chose to do that well I mean they
just said you know sing a song it was
easy to be hard recorded it is a benefit
a Broadway benefit and here was the show
and I was like I'm gonna sing Xavier wow
that's very cool and then there's a
third audition they're still not sure uh
they made us wait to the last second
they did you want that movie more than
you wanted to win American Idol oh god
yes because again who gets the second
chance and then that big like so and
then it was a dream role you know like I
didn't know much of the play but I knew
the music and I was like I don't want to
sing this music you know cuz even when I
was on Idol Barry Manilow had arranged
one of the songs weekend in New England
as if it wasn't I'm telling you so
people looked at that it was like
shooting mines it's a Fe so when that's
why they all came up everybody was like
Jennifer Hudson for Evie I don't even
know the character name I was talking
about Oh any Fe yeah and so those that
people still think that I was singing
and I'm telling you on the show and I
was like no it was weekend in New
England that was arranged like an
Italian you know one of the things I
love about your story is that really
that was supposed to be let's be honest
that was supposed to be Beyonce's movie
that you know I get the chills even
saying this yeah I bet you do too
that really was her movie that that was
the idea it became your movie well you
know that's true and you're smiling
I mean you know that's true and that's a
remarkable thing yes thank you
was there rivalry with the cheese sense
do you think or did everyone on that set
sense that it was becoming your movie
they used to all say it I didn't
understand and they would tell me they
they're like you have the amazing thing
is you have no clue what's going on and
like Jamie Foxx he sat me down and he
was like you know you're gonna win an
Oscar for this and the host fat started
to say it and Beyonce we were in the
studio
and she was like you do realize no one
gets a start like this like the the
placement that you have and this
opportunity of this platform it's like
this is so neat like that you would get
this you know
and when we were shooting I mean come on
I'm in a movie with Danny Glover Eddie
Murphy
may I say Jamie Foxx ain't nobody stood
in look Jennifer Hudson at least that's
what I would think it's crazy because I
have all those people I mean I think
Eddie got a lot of acclaim Jamie Foxx
certainly gets a lot of acclaim but but
but but you say Beyonce was gracious to
you though during the filming right it
wasn't any kind of rivalry or anything
like that that's kind of refreshing you
hear because you know because people can
get really territorial about it you know
hey this is my movie not yours calm down
you know the way the movie is written
it's always been effort oliday yeah and
it made you yeah and you have that song